it keeps happening and it has to stop  Jessica Alba got emotional during the  Teen Choice Awards on Sunday when she  stood on stage to introduce several  young family members of recent victims  of gun violence  um camera a few weeks ago  Cameron's world was turned upside down  when he learned his father alton  sterling was killed while selling CDs  out of a store in Baton Rouge tonight we  stand together with these teams  and to this violence the tribute also  included singer neo performing Marvin  Gaye's classic hit what's going on he  later joined Alba on stage to deliver a  powerful message these you ought to  stand up right now and take out your  phones take a picture of all of these  courageous teams standing here asking  for the violence to stop  you